Amazon wanted production company to help
them make Stargate but which production
company do we want to get involved
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so for a while now I've been telling you
guys if you're a regular stock tracker
that Stargate will have to have a
co-production company to help Amazon and
MGM to actually make it they're going to
need a company that actually owns Studio
space for a start and somebody that will
work alongside penguin in a Parker Mark
focus is company in the development and
then the production of the series movie
both
so which production company has been
rumored and which production company do
I think is actually most likely to get
involved with the new Stargate franchise
let's start with the outsider Warner
Brothers now Warner Brothers actually
does have a reasonably decent working
relationship with MGM already the recent
Creed movies were all made in
partnership with MGM and Warner Brothers
there's been a few other projects as
well but the interesting thing and the
rumor that I've heard recently was that
Amazon are looking to get a big deal to
work in cooperation with somebody like
Warner Brothers to rent Studio space
they are planning to produce five or six
cinematic movies a year and they believe
that the only way they can do that is if
they actually strike up a partnership
deal with a big production company one
of the rumors I've been hearing is is
that they've been negotiating with
Warner Brothers to rent Studio space but
to also partnership with several
cinematic projects now that is one
possibility and also possibly why
Jennifer saki is so Keen for the first
Stargate outing to be a cinematic movie
A cinematic movie done in Partnership
maybe with Warner Brothers now this may
also be one of the reasons why this is
taking so long Amazon do want to do this
kind of on the cheap they want to have
this done in partnership with somebody
else but also this deal potentially with
Warner Brothers is a big deal it will be
worth hundreds of millions of dollars
and it would allow Amazon to rent
exclusively a very large area of Studio
space currently Warner Brothers has one
of the largest Studio spaces in
Hollywood but they also have some
Financial issues Financial issues that
this deal would seriously help to
alleviate but it is the outside
possibility for the new Stargate project
there's a couple of other companies that
I have heard mentioned one being in
Lionsgate now Lionsgate have done loads
of TV shows over the years they own the
Stars Network that did shows like
Outlander and the Spartacus series
they've done loads of movies including
Hunger Games The Glass Onion for Netflix
the Rambo series the saw series The Day
After Tomorrow one of my personal
favorites it was Lionsgate that are
potentially interested but the Amazon
were not so Keen they are looking for a
larger partner one production company
though that has been mentioned a couple
of times now is a legendary pictures now
legendary pictures recently did Carnival
row with Amazon and they've done a
couple of other big TV projects as well
it's also interesting to know that
legendary pictures were actually
involved in the expanse they also did
Lost in Space for Netflix and recently
did the short night sky series for
Amazon
this is a production company that
definitely have the expertise to pull
off something like the Stargate
franchise and I have heard this rumor a
couple of times but I have to admit not
for a little while the rumor that I hear
over and over again though is that
Amazon are gonna get into bed with Sony
Pictures now Sony do own a very large
studio space mgm's old Studio space of
Culver City now the relationship between
MGM and Sony Pictures has not always
been a good one but to be honest Sony
pictures are kind of known for being
slightly awkward to deal with look at
the relationship between Marvel and Sony
Pictures over Spider-Man it's not always
been a particularly Cooperative deal and
even though it's all worked out a couple
of times in the last few years it really
did look like the relationship between
Marvel and Sony over Spider-Man was
going to collapse
it's also been told to me actually that
Sony are very hardcore about getting
their back end they do want to get paid
and they negotiate hard is that
something Amazon are going to be wanting
to get involved with well they have had
a couple of big hits with Sony at Amazon
over the last couple of years it is Sony
that produces the boys arguably one of
Amazon's biggest hits over the last few
years they've done a few shows that
haven't been so popular uh Mad Dogs
sneaky peek The Tick the tick has got
Awful Truth Seekers and The Wheel of
Time just to mention a couple the other
thing though that is interesting is that
the god of war is being co-produced by
Sony and Amazon
but more interestingly also by penguin
in a Parker penguin in a Parker Mark
fergus's company is doing the
development work on God of War and again
if you're a regular sidetracker you'll
know that we've been talking about
penguin in a park doing the development
work for Stargate for quite some time
now and this has been confirmed by other
MGM insiders like Jenny Steven is it
possible they would might continue that
partnership straight into Stargate well
it would kind of make sense wouldn't it
the deal is already there the
partnership is already working the
people that would generally make God of
walk and then also be working on
Stargate it is a distinct possibility
but has Sony ever really been involved
with Stargate before
yes they co-produced two seasons of
Stargate Atlantis with MGM so they
already kind of have a vested interest
in the Stargate franchise
and I can't help but love the idea
of Stargate being filmed at Culver City
mgm's old Studios isn't that kind of
like it coming home now a lot of the
people have said that actually they
would really like Stargate to be filmed
up in Vancouver again but when Amazon
was buying MGM they did have some
trouble with the FTC the head of the FTC
A lady called Khan
[Music]
was um very against the merger and
Amazon made a lot of compromises to get
it through the FTC as quickly as
possible one of those compromises
whether they agreed to do a large
percentage of mgm's new projects in the
United States the idea being that it
would generate tax revenue something the
government's quite like and also
stimulate TV and movie production in the
United States
so it would look like a big franchise
like Stargate but potentially TV series
our movies would want to be filmed in
America because it would feel a big part
of that quota for Amazon
and getting filmed at mgm's Old Studios
there are elements of MGM that probably
won't like that because there's a little
bit of a bitter taste in the mouth from
having to sell the studios and there's
been some difficult relationships in the
past but
to be honest that's irrelevant now that
Amazon are in charge and Amazon do have
a good working relationship with Sony so
if I was a betting man
I would put all of my money on Stargate
being co-produced by Sony pictures but
guys get to the concert tell me what
you're thinking who would you like
Amazon and MGM to partner up with to
produce this does Sony have the pedigree
that we want producing Stargate or is
Warner Brothers the company for you
personally I look at what they've done
with the DC and I'm not so sure
but guys get into the comments and tell
me exactly what you're thinking if you
are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification
really helps us out and you will never
miss any of our new videos also you can
go to patreon.com forward slash
Sidetrack where you can see most of our
new videos first and for a small
contribution that really helps Channel
out you get to see without the adverts
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time foreign
[Music]